[Music]
talk talk fast you first my name is
Sarah Connor
August 29 1997 supposed to be Judgment
Day
but I changed the future
saved three billion lives
enough of a resume for you know
the future
change our feet
[Music]
protects you
never seen one like you before almost
human I am human
just enhanced
why do you care what happens to her
because I was her I can see you're very
upset I'm going to help you protect the
girl
because of me
if you don't make it
everybody dies expect a big pain brother
whole body's a weapon
all right
[Music]
and this is all over I am going to kill
you I understand
[Music]
I'll be back
can you try
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no the Iguana I I see those two yes
can you know either me simply Jana bah
Hey yes you go let's go we're running
late so we're gonna piss idea see
Juana's cincuenta daniela rooms
[Music]
that is not your father come with me or
you're dead in the next 30 seconds
I only mechanical make it even better to
put it faster
play us you Kenny you're my mission
[Music]
what is that my name is Sarah Connor I
hunt terminators enough of a resume for
you
how do we stop this thing
I'm going to help you change the future
I'm done running I'm gonna spend and
fight
you can't die
if you don't make it
everybody dies why not just let me have
it
because we're not machines metal mother
[Music]
last night I was standing there looking
at the monitor on one camera was Linda
Hamilton and on another camera on
Schwarzenegger I thought holy [ __ ] I'm
making a Terminator movie then let's
recapture that tone
it's r-rated [ __ ] grin it's gritty it's
fast its intense work hard and play hard
and this is what this movie was all
about Jane Nestle's fresh vision and
like what he did in that bull his action
is yeah
it's just a fast white-knuckle ride you
better watch your ass I hunt terminators
metal [ __ ]
if it follows tonally in the footsteps
of t1 and t2 that adrenaline rush
feeling that sense of terror
in this film the
action is 10 times bigger it's
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
relentless it just does not stop
just [ __ ] insect
two days ago I had this nice simple life
no it's a nightmare
[Music]
stop
[Music]
[Applause]
who are you my name is Sarah Connolly I
never seen one like you before
almost human
I am human
why do you care what happens to her
because I was hurt
now do we win we win by keeping you
alive
[Music]
keeping you alive terminator dark state
is the direct sequel determinator to
pick up the characters that we knew from
Terminator 2 and carry them forward we
get to continue the story with Jim
backed in the writing in the producing
chair
he knows the material nobody else
I think for fans of the franchise the
biggest thing is that Linda's returning
people love this character people love
Sarah
being back is wonderful saris a force to
be reckoned with and I was ready to
explore them I'm delighted to work again
with the Hamilton they work with Cameron
Tamela Clinton or the new cast
there's no film history captured that
tall those first two films it's great
it's fast its intense
and it's just a white-knuckle ride
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]